- [Voiceover] As you might already know
or you're finding out through this video,
a new SAT, a new SAT is coming.
And the first administration
of that new SAT
is going to be on March 2016.
So the first question
you're probably asking,
"well, does this apply to me?"
And a simple rule of thumb is if
you're going to need to apply to college
before March 2016, and
so that's the majority
of the folks who are
applying in the fall of 2015,
well then the new SAT is probably
going to come a little
bit too late for you.
But if you're applying
for college after that,
so the fall of 2016,
you could probably use either SAT,
the new SAT or the current SAT.
And for sure if you're
applying for college
in the fall of 2017, 2018,
you're probably going
to focus on the new SAT.
So applying, let me write this,
so this most likely will apply
to folks applying for college
fall 2016 and after.
So with that out of the way,
what's the whole point?
What is different about the new SAT?
And I'll do another video
where I'll go into the details
and I look at some of the sample items,
and we think about how
they're different from
the current SAT, but at a very high level,
the goal is to really just be more aligned
with what you learn in school.
More aligned, more aligned with school.
And the things that you need to know
to be college ready.
So, this even includes the vocabulary.
The old SAT or you could
say the current SAT
was famous for some words
that you might not use in
your everyday conversations,
or you might not use in, even in college
while the new SAT is going
to be more aligned with that.
It still helps to know vocabulary,
but they're going to be vocabulary words
that you'll find using a lot in college
or in your later life.
So, it's going to be more aligned
with what you learn in school,
and at a very general level,
it's going to be simpler.
And it's going to be simpler in terms of
the number of sections,
and we'll talk about that a little bit.
And you're going to have more time
for a question in general.
It's also going to be simpler in terms
of how you think about taking the test.
The old or the current SAT,
you have to think about,
ok if I guess on this,
there's going to be a
penalty for guessing.
While on the new SAT, while on the new SAT
there's no penalty for guessing.
So if you can answer it, answer it.
If you can rule out some choices,
still answer it.
You should just always
try to answer questions,
so you don't have to really think about
the gamesmanship of it,
you just answer, answer the questions.
So the next thing you're
probably thinking about-
well, what are the sections,
and how is it actually going to be,
how is it actually going to be scored?
So, what I've pre-drawn right over here,
and I hope you can read it,
the writing is a little bit small,
is I'm comparing the
current/old SAT up here,
so this line right over here is the,
depending on your point of view,
the current/old SAT.
The one that is "sun-setting",
going into 2016.
Your last chance to take
this is January 2016.
And then this one is the new one,
so this right over here,
that is the new SAT.
That's the one that we are talking about.
So, big picture, you see
that the current SAT,
you have three math sections.
Two of them are 25 minutes,
one of them is 20 minutes.
And it's not necessarily going
to be given in this order.
In fact, it's likely
to be all shuffled up.
While on the new SAT, you
have two math sections.
One of them's 25 minutes
and one is longer.
It's 55 minutes, but they only have
those two sections,
and as you can see here,
with the longer section,
you're allowed to use a calculator.
And so you'll probably see questions
that may be helpful to use a calculator.
And then the other one,
you don't use a calculator.
And you see that the time is,
let's see you're comparing,
this is 70 minutes and 54 questions
versus 80 minutes and 58 questions.
So on average, you have a little bit,
you have more time per question.
And now we can look here in the reading,
again you have three sections of reading.
Two 25 minute sections,
one 20 minute sections.
Now you have one 65
minute reading sections.
And once again, on average,
you have more time per question
in the new reading sections.
And I just want to make it very clear,
it's not necessarily going to
be administered in this order.
I'm just showing you so
we can kind of compare.
Reading to reading or math to math.
Then in the current SAT, you have,
the one that you would take
if you took it in 2015,
you have two writing sections
or two, I guess you could say,
two non-essay writing sections.
One is 25 minutes, one is 10 minutes.
And then you also have an essay section
that helps form part
of your writing score.
While in the new SAT, you have just a
35 minute writing section and
then the essay is optional.
This little green thing right over here,
this is the experimental section
in the current SAT,
and there might be experimental sections
in the new SAT as well.
So this is kind of a comparison of things,
and kind of the big takeaways are
you have fewer sections here,
more time on average per question,
and then the essay is optional.
So, how is all of this going to be scored?
Well, in the current SAT,
let me write it over here,
so let me write the current SAT,
or you can view it as the old SAT
if you want to view it that way.
Current/old SAT and I want to compare it
to the new SAT
In the current one, math is scored
on a scale from 200 to 800.
And that's still going to
be the case in the new SAT.
Math is going to be scored
on a scale from 200 to 800.
Now on the current SAT,
you have a reading score
based on these three
sections right over here
that's going to be scored from 200 to 800.
Now in the new SAT, reading and writing
is going to be combined.
So reading plus writing is going
to give you a 200 to 800 points of score.
So this is going to be-
I don't know whether to
write it in blue or orange
so maybe I write it in both
or let me, I'll write it in another color.
200 to 800 points for this.
And in the current or old SAT,
you have writing/essay
as a separate section.
Writing/essay and this also
gave you 200 to 800 points.
While in the new SAT, you just have
the essay section is separate from
the writing in terms of score.
So you just have the essay,
and once again, this is optional.
This is an optional thing.
You have the essay which is optional,
I'll write it again even though
I wrote it down here as well.
It's optional and that's
going to be scored
from 2 to 4, sorry 2 to 8 points.
So, what are the big takeaways here?
Well in the current SAT,
when people give you their SAT score,
they're going to give you a score,
if you add these up,
the lowest possible score's going to be
200 plus 200 plus 200
which is going to be 600.
Then the highest one is 2400.
So it's on a 2400 point scale.
That's the current/old SAT.
Well the new one, well people are
likely to give their scores,
the lowest possible score is 200 plus 200
which is going to be 400,
and the highest one is going to 1600.
800 in math, 800 in reading plus writing,
and then people might have also
an optional essay score
that is as high as 8 points.
So, those are the big takeaways.
Hopefully that helps you a little bit.
And in a future video, I'll
look at the actual items
and think about how things have changed.